not a boy not a girl it's a
gender-neutral baby girl so I'm going to
do with my kids nowadays many parents
find out the sex of their child before
before the baby's born
s waiting to hear it's a boy or it's a
girl and some families are exploring
another option 10 news reporter Liz
Crawford met one Florida family raising
a gender-neutral child
instead of a boy
or a girl gender-neutral babies are
known as babies did they really set up a
box with balloons just to have that
while she said it they really did and
you know what and this whole the whole
feel of this so far is propaganda-ish
it's like a welcome like welcome this
kind of ideology yeah yeah this is I
mean I'm just thinking right like why is
this necessary that that that actual
Nightly News Local Nightly News that is
being pushed into people's homes at
dinner time or any time of the day is
trying to normalize this mental illness
[ __ ] I just find it funny that
someone went to the store bought blue
pink balloons and boxes just for this
babies
unless someone comes out screaming in a
second and says how insane this is and
and punches this girl in the face the
comments on but the term baby is already
gender neutral somebody said that means
only parents and trusted caregivers know
that baby's Anatomy they say the gender
part comes later and is left up to the
child
[Music]
revealing the sex of your unborn baby
has become a little silly
huge gender reveal parties are popular
with themes touchdowns or tutus who
started that huge forest fire because of
their gender reveal fireworks
a gender reveal party sparked this
massive Blaze that's still burning
people died probably thousands of
animals died firefighters died because
we needed to find because you wanted to
make such a fuss about something that
happened how much of a geek 50 million
times in recent history to find out have
a whole party to find out you're having
a daughter I hate to break it to you
your baby's not that special nobody's is
he's gonna grow up to be insignificant
just like your entire bloodline not
really there's eight billion people
walking around the planet right now
insignificant insignificant not that
special it's not and and the whole you
know consider all the people that have
already lived and died billions and
billions but you gotta burn down for us
so that we can find out that you're
having a boy congratulations idiots
peons and whether you're happy having a
boy or girl
yes the Florida man
alligator chomping into a watermelon and
Bluetooth
a proclamation to the world it's a boy
see it goes right in but for some
families oh I love this thank you the
gender reveal won't happen anytime soon
we did not assign a sex at Birth which
means when they were born
um we they had genitals and we know what
they are we just chose to decided to
raise a freak early on indicate anything
about gender meet Sparrow
hormones that come with those all the
hormones that come with those genitals
indicate certain characteristics you
name your kids sparrow and the kid
doesn't have a sex that's like it's like
you're asking for this kid to get
bullied yeah you're raising a freak
because you have zero zero item name is
knowledge about zero knowledge and
understanding about the reality of human
nature children are you know they they
bully they come from broken homes they
they're they're hurt themselves they're
they may come from lovely homes and they
still bully because they're still
figuring out what's right and what's
wrong so they're now giving them a
Target Little Sparrow Pro is going to
get shot out of the sky in kindergarten
going duck hunt adorable 11 month old
baby is Sparrow a boy or girl
the answer to be determined my own
mother did not know uh Sparrow's uh
genitals for the first three months
even though she was living with us at
the time oh hell no hell no could you
even imagine if you ever married a girl
that pulled some [ __ ] like this well
maybe it's I'd be a girl don't don't get
too quick to make assumptions oh I'll
kill you and her I'll go to jail for it
this is crazy women could you imagine
can't see the baby's genitals gender
neutral meaning Sparrow will decide
gender when older even Sparrow's birth
certificate says sex unknown we are in
no way prohibiting Sparrow from having a
gender and we're not forcing them to be
one gender or another I'm so annoyed
like this is no way how does the
hospital allowed like that just shows
that the West is it's the fall it's the
fall the dollar doesn't mean anything
this [ __ ] is going if you go to a
hospital have a baby and the doctors
can't write down male or female of what
the baby science the basic science of if
it was born a male or a female this is
the problems we're worried about when
the regular Average Joe is about a legit
become a slave in years once they stop
printing money out the Wazoo we're
toasts we are toast says the family was
in inspired to raise Sparrow without a
known gender after their older child
Hazel discovered gender around the age
of four oh my God what do you say when
someone asks you if you have a little
brother or sister how do you respond I
say I have a little sibling because
they're my little siblings so when Hazel
or brother was four Hazel got to decide
the psychological makeup of her infant
infant sibling instead of the adults
running the show now you have the
inmates running the Asylum literally I
say it's my sibling like you thought
like their thoughts getting planted into
this poor kid's brain if you came home
from kindergarten and I was having
another baby and you said that you
wanted that baby to be that baby wasn't
a boy or girl that baby was a spider I
would patch you on the head and say
that's cute and we would sing Itsy Bitsy
Spider and then we would carry on with
our day I'm not going to let you just
convince this child that it's a spider
from the day it was born I mean
literally that's how ridiculous this
sounds to me how absurd this sounds to
me it's child abuse
um no one here in the house has we
didn't want Sparrow to grow up in a an
environment devoid of gender we because
that's not really yeah it's not real
life we want them to get to experience
all genders so like them going out in
public and getting treated like a girl
and then getting treated like a boy and
then getting getting treated like
someone you can't tell shows them what
the diverse options are sparrows
closed Facebook group called parenting
babies roughly three
mouth now what if Sparrow 350 freaks in
the coming years am I a boy or a girl
Abdul get the Rocks I would tell them
that they're the only one who gets to
decide that that I can't know that
well do you feel like a boy do you feel
like a girl so let me put you on the
spot with this question so I told you I
have a daughter
the walls in her Nursery are pink yeah
do you think I'm nuts
no I think you're following a
comfortable social narrative as for
Sparrow it's wait and see a gender
reveal Ari believes is worth the wait
there's no way this can go wrong people
will be like oh well the child to be
confused
no if if gender is really something in
you
then no one's going to change that this
poor baby there are varying degrees of
gender-neutral parenting you have
families like sparrows who are choosing
not to disclose the sex of their baby
others are just encouraging their
children to play with all kinds of toys
and wear whatever color they want so
inclusive props to them so inclusive
props to them yeah yeah this should be a
important this is filmed this was filmed
as a sweet story about a family who's
making different choices when it should
be filmed as a warning with red flags
all over it of child abuse because this
child you are putting this heavy heavy
[ __ ] on a little baby imagine showing
this to like Russian is now going to
come home and go how come I'm not a boy
or a girl like everybody else how come
I'm a circus freak because that's what
happens you came home okay do you
remember you came home that's six seven
years old and you said Mommy how come I
can't be a Red Sox fan like all my
friends and I was like because we're
Yankees fans and that's how it is and we
sat that down and we talked about the
Yankees and we talked about the Red Sox
and we talked about Babe Ruth and we we
had a whole conversation okay that was
Heavy enough for a seven-year-old that
here I am trying to make sure that he's
a Yankees fan and he just wants to be a
Red Sox fan like his friends could you
imagine what this child is going to go
through this poor little Sparrow this
poor little baby bird is gonna be a
freak because that's way more serious
way more serious all right thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe so much join the Discord
and follow me on Instagram at sunnyfast
Sparrow is going to be asking you for a
job in 20 years